hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu epic sky
map pathetischen blablabla zusammen mit
dem hier bei halli hallo wie gehts mir
geht's gut ich habe gerade eine clutch
von hinten bekommen aber ich weiß nicht
woher kommst du das ich hab weiß auch
nicht wann ich habe übrigens auch gar
nix zum schlagen oder schießen
ich hab den renn renn renn renn renn
renn ratte wir schauen uns gegenseitig
zu er hat sehr gut geklappt ja ok aber
du kannst hier sind kommend blogs also
das war wegen nein das ist nicht als
wichtig wollen jetzt hier lang hier lang
ein wenig okay doch einmal wird das
schlafen legen für mich okay bevor ich
noch irgendwie nicht mehr dass born sehr
gut sehr gut weg und noch mal sehe ich
schon wieder so ein tintenfisch also in
der letzten folge haben wir auf jeden
fall schon mal einen fisch getötet er
dennoch im kader des clubs also ein boss
genau das check point können einfach
abbauen und dann kommt das wasser
entspringt und trotzdem nicht gute
leistung ja das einwurf trank der
geschwindigkeit
na dann kann ich das auch gar nicht
offene ohne dahinter was aber gar nicht
auf ja warte alter ist dass kassel
hoffentlich bringt übrigens nicht weiter
mit diesem komischen springs nenne ich
habe auch noch sprung verstärken das
heißt es jetzt richtig op soll jetzt
einfach mal benutzten den sprungkraft
links ich weiß nicht ich das bloß und
mit läuft nicht wir hatten ja eben
eigentlich milch getrunken
das wäre halt nicht mehr denen die
sprung verstärkung haben
also ich denke mal dürfen wir nicht okay
dann ich probier's doch erst mal an aber
es geht auch ohne das ist gut wir sind
jetzt diese komischen blätter branche
hat einfach nur durch das ist eigentlich
auch aus der perspektive
aber hier ist ein kleiner checkpoint
anscheinend vor ich bin halt richtig gut
bei mir halt das leider ich freu mich
schon wenn ich die neue grafikkarten
habe ich hab's geschafft ich habe heute
kommen sobald eine neue und da kann ich
auch endlich shader spiel nicht wenn ein
fach bekommen genau drei wochen will ich
muss auch mit der zeit gehen und endlich
den shader installieren ich war damals
immer so a der shader zu viele bugs weil
wenn man in einer höhle war unter
scheint die sonne auf einmal durch die
blöcke durch das fand ich jetzt nicht so
geil aber mittlerweile in ja definitiv
selbst custom eisen wie es so schön auf
englisch heißt selbst für sich selber
einstellen wie man die fackeln haben
will was sich bewegen soll
und das sieht auf jeden fall sehr sehr
geil aus mittlerweile deswegen freue ich
mich auf jeden fall auf meine neue
grafikkarte ich habe nämlich eine nvidia
geforce gtx 680 will auch haben ich weiß
ganz genau wie meine heißt aber ich habe
also ich weiß schon wie die heißt aber
die ist auf jeden fall nicht so ein
profi tyler merke ich mir den namen
lieber nicht aber auf jeden fall läuft
bei meiner auch scheider irgendwie dass
ich erst dass es gut bei mir läuft
scheidet mit 32 grad
aber halt auch nur mit den schlechtesten
einstellung also mit renner dissens auf
normal und so was alles was möchte ich
euch haben so da kommt da schon an
achtung ich schaff das und da bin ich
verspreche ich alter hast nicht
geschafft der letzte sprung wo wir
achten rum warte ich mach mal ganz kurz
wir machen das was ich könnte ich könnt
ihr könnt ihr dann eben einfach
ich habe die rabatte geben verknüpfen
ganz kurz hoch ja ja ich habe diese
blöcke gegeben also ich nehme mir auch
das sieht man jetzt nicht dass du da ja
ich hab den sprung noch geschafft ja wo
geht's hier lang ich weiß nicht ich
folge dir einfach mal alter folgen
einfach mancher lux
das schaffe ich noch ihr okay alter ist
es echt krass richtig schnell wir
brauchen jetzt aber auch richtig gut
geworden
hier könnte man ein cooles baumhaus
bauen du bist schon oben oder aber ich
bin schon ganz am ende wieder einmal
gucke ich gucke auf dich herr abgleich
du bist du bist ja wo bisher dabei sei
stetig
und noch einer
la la la la la la la la la la la la da
bin ich gehe weg was ich wollte ich
nicht komplett rotter schubst sie wollte
ich nur so wieder zurück auf die wolke
nummer 1 mit geht mit einer 1 mit geben
so auch ich kriege schon bei jedem
sprung
das bad ist auf jeden fall sehr geil vor
allem mit diesem geschwindigkeits boost
das sehr sehr episch und ich habe ihn
gar nicht mehr leider nein ich habe die
macht sieht sehr gut aus
ich bin gleich wieder ein 1 1 beim
checkpoint havariekommando wieder
ich brauche nahrung von nahrung
unbedingt okay ich bräuchte es war noch
einfach reich marotten oder so und so
wartet das darf nicht mehr springen ich
hab ein halbes leben nur noch wenn ich
wieder aufgaben dann verliere ich wär
ein halbes jahr
ich habe es aber auch nichts mehr zu
essen ich damit sagen klopp wir finden
noch was irgendwie überall ist brutal
wir finden noch butter genau
daran scheinen ich bin hier oben kalt
beim checkpoint ja so viele tische folge
die rohr verzicht ach da ist unseren
jumping pula müssen wir rein wirtschaft
mann wurde nach da unten okay
schafft man wo du schaffst es definitiv
nicht new york dpa da sind bestimmt
wieder solche blöcke lesens nicht
diesmal muss man aufpassen welche hier
fest ui okay ich bin hinter dir
da kann es nicht mehr kann es nicht mehr
ich kann auch hier mein ganzes essen
gegeben da müsstest du einfach nur
normalerweise noch viel schneller rennen
können
du bist doch die leiche lag in den
checkpoint erstmal nehmen wieder ich bin
also hier lang und dann hier überall wo
bin ich denn hier
ich bin anscheinend auf der butter insel
aha warte ich bin auf dem weg
das stadion gerade provider auf einmal
nehmen hat aber nicht ganz so geklappt
ich mir das vorgestellt habe da hinten
waren wir doch schon okay da waren wir
schon glaube ich ja da war ich dann hier
lang noch wirklich braucht vielleicht
auch mal wieder was zu essen
ich habe ja nichts mehr ja wir müssen
mal wieder was finden hier ist eine
kiste wasser und milch nur toll von
sekunden schnelligkeit was aber hat auch
ohne schnelligkeit geschafft oder manila
hat sich aber ich hab' ich hatte ja noch
herzlich ich hab das jetzt gerade eine
ich hab keinen geschwindigkeit
ich hätte aber noch tränke für dich mit
sprung verstecke und geschwindigkeit nur
noch sechs sekunden geschwindigkeit
ok ich hab's geschafft und jetzt meine
geschwindigkeit weg gut auch wenn man
später muss für die eigene kiste alle
politischen zwecken
wenn ich jetzt habe ich auf jeden fall
entwickelte bitterfeld ist wirklich
bitter
das war natürlich auch island ok ok
milch sachen rein legen also nicht alle
aber nur die puschen
ach so ich habe jetzt postens
herausgenommen so diese ganzen blöcke
euro er hat gelogen das war eigentlich
die butter insel shutter island island
meine güte ist das ein scherzkeks hat
ist er unglaublich ich kann nicht mehr
vor lachen
ich kann nicht mehr wie zu essen habe
fast nichts mehr
aufpassen nicht wohl aber geht arbeiten
nicht an tempo aber kein verständnis
wenn ihr über die läufer läuft hier oben
habe ich nahrung
ja es werden ganze eventuell in äpfeln
wenn du mir irgendwas runterschubsen
gerade gerne hättest du denn da okay
hier oben kann man auch schweiß einfach
runter danke
ich stelle schon mal hier auf nachbar
schön jetzt muss ich das nur noch wir
schaffen das geht eigentlich also ich
warte hier oben mal auf dich wenn man
diese komischen kleinen wieder zu hause
ja geil fand ich auch sehr witzig man
jetzt schon ich mir den komischen sprung
ach komm ich leg mich schon mal ins bett
gute nacht na gut dachte einfach aber
als jemand vorbeikommt sich neben mich
liegt mit auf den weg ich in den schlaf
kuschelt nein ich brauche eine gute
nacht geschichte zieht der ball einschob
ja und die moral von der geschicht muss
wissen wer der braut im contra nicht
okay hallo ich hin
okay er wolle apple ja wir haben wieder
weil wir uns so fett gefressen haben
hier jeder eine doppel behälter gefeiert
und natürlich die geht ja auch gar nicht
anders
hilfe
jetzt geht es natürlich wieder raus hier
ne du musst du hier stinkt's das
geburtsfeier resistenz was er das denn
du hast gute leistung direkt lass das
mal mit mir meine nerven
ich bin wir hier unten alte ich wollte
ich gar nicht bring dich um ich habe
auch keine sachen mehr äpfel mal ich bin
auch grad ins wasser gefallen ist
in sachen wiederholen und dann mich zu
dir das ist ja den checkpoint wo bist du
auf dem dach oder martina schlagers ich
habe eine idee wo wir eine grube gräbt
fällt selbst hinein
das beispiel gaal lasst mich darunter
geschlagen und wer es dann besser auf
das dach geortet okay aber wir schaffen
das wieder hoch sag mal wenn oben bist
dann technisch zu den mafia
ich bin okay wir müssen jetzt die
anderen auf jeden fall erstmal wieder zu
machen sonst schaffst du ja ich lebe
noch
wir müssen
walter kopp ich bin hier hilfe ich habe
angst nur wegen die us wirtschaft es
geht so die höhe wie das wasser gefallen
muss wieder zu dir passiert kommt da
nicht raus
schade ich wollte ich da ich wollte
eigentlich wollte ich dann durch die du
mein freund mein freund der
kupferstecher müssen wir laut dessen
bett bekamen wir ja dort ist wichtig für
alter wir müssen da eine eigene ich gar
nicht war das schon richtig von mir
bekommen konnten
es ist darüber springen das geht glaube
ich oder ich weiß nicht wo ich gehe das
geht nicht
bartels und das geht und funktionsfähig
den punkt wie lange die karte wohl
überhaupt noch ich glaube aber nicht
lange weil obwohl da hinten jetzt noch
weiter da oben jetzt auch noch weiter
okay da ist so ein blog hier ist dann
block da muss man drauf springen hier
meine aufzuspringen crafter und jetzt
also geschafft war ja auch mal wieder
selber ja geht nicht einmal da oben
stehen aber wird die da oben stehen ich
springe wir das wasserbecken okay
natürlich einfach zu mir
bei dem anfang also bei der ersten folge
noch voller ernst dabei die pforten und
mittlerweile ja gut einmal geht er okay
jetzt schlagen jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal nicht mehr nehme ich hoffe
schlagen wenn wir beide runter fallen
würden das irgendwie panne so wäre
suboptimal
ja kann man natürlich auch so ausdrücken
aber ich wollte jetzt ja nicht komisch
ist legte das deutsche ja okay ich hab's
geschafft
ich brauche drei länder in denen stars
wie mario style ok huk coburg war ich
bin drin sein was allerdings auch es
geschafft ich auch ich bin immer noch
ich verfolgte ich nett aus dem wasser
will help you jump lookup seien hoch
schauen ob wir werden gleich richtig
verschleudert du musst springen einfach
nur der mecki auch gerade ich bin fast
tot
er merkt man sonst im goldenen apfel ich
hab's geschafft nach drogen dir drin ist
milch damit unsere links wieder vergeht
ich komme da bin ich seitdem ich super
wer wo ich kenne die argumente für die
apple kehre ich bin mir nicht über
allgemein sagen das ist alles in der
nächsten aufnahmen entdeckten lesen
spiel dabei der laden stunde wirklich
ihr ging ja schnell vorbei das ging sehr
schnell
tja da meine lieben freunde dann will
ich einfach sagen da kommt das mädchen
noch ganz gut schafft neben weil gar
nicht einfach hin zum mit eine stunde
später einer geht noch
na ja jetzt was aber verkaufe ich hab's
geschafft
was kannst du etwas mit teleportieren
kann ich sagen machen wir schluss für
diese folge wie immer wenn es euch
gefallen hat dürft ihr eine positive
bewertung abgeben konnte wird sich da
total drüber freunde wird feucht
positiven bewertung
ja aber richtig und meine arbeit ich
haben wir hier mache
am sonntagmorgen dem oder ganz unten
sieht man seinen namen sonntagmorgen
zwei uhr für uns am morgen na gut freude
wie sieht es beim nächsten mal
beziehungsweise nächsten folge bei ghom
morgen auf seinem kanal teils genau bis
zum nächsten fall genau